across Europe there are lots of strange
tourist attractions that started out as
useful public transport infrastructure
Venice has its gondolas lots of cities
have cable cars and funicular Railways
and fun shell here the capital of
Madeira has the basket carts they are
wooden toboggans on smooth Runners that
are powered by people in straw hats
pushing them
and uh there aren't any seat belts
from the start they use this Ledges to
bring some some wood from the mountains
to to the town by the sea after that
they adapt for tourists
in total we are 154 men we have about 60
baskets running most of the days the
toboggan is made of wood normal wood and
uh if he is is stick to the floor we put
some grease under the the basket and it
slides much better we have a workshop
where we fix the baskets and we build
new ones and we keep rotating the
baskets
there's not much to hold on to here okay
this is a two kilometer ride the top
speed is about 30 kilometers an hour
the most startling thing of all is that
this is a regular probe there is actual
traffic there is a taxi
just down here and uh
yeah
oh that is beautiful
[Music]
foreign
thank you
sometimes
a solid water
game Russia okay
I know on camera
no seat belt to 30 kilometers an hour
downhill
definitely feels like
ah of course if you want to get back up
uh you'll have to take the cable car or
a taxi as for how to get the toboggans
up well actually that's the answer to
that